and welcome to the mcgovern institute's
first ever story slam
i'm kirsty bennett founder of mitel a
storytelling program for mit
i'll be your moderator for the next hour
or so as we hear seven mcgovern
storytellers share true stories
on the theme of resilience we are
thrilled to host this event as part of
the mcgovern's 20th anniversary
celebration
and we are particularly delighted to
have the institute's co-founder
laurie hart mcgovern in our virtual
audience welcome
i've always been a fan of the mcgovern
even from afar
so much so that i bought both of my
babies to have their brains scanned
there in the name of scientific research
there's still only one and four but
maybe they'll be brain scientists too
one day
but in working on tonight's program it
opened up so much more of the mcgovern
to me
and i know it will for you too through
the power of these stories you're about
to discover the diversity of discipline
at the institute
and really get to know the scientists
that call it home that's right
we are putting scientists right out of
their comfort zone
and asking them to talk about themselves
as well as their work
and to our theme tonight resilience i
think it's fair to say that
everyone watching this event tonight
wherever you are in the world
knows something about resilience it's
been quite a year
so tonight we're going to celebrate that
very human strength
this hour you will hear stories of
failed experiments
of crushing setbacks of overwhelming
doubt
these seven storytellers have
experienced and overcome
it all tonight each one will share a
true
personal story of grit perseverance and
resilience
we have two judges for today's slam
maddie sofia host of npr's daily science
podcast shortwave
there she is and tina husman say a
senior writer at science news
hello tina maddie and cena will have the
difficult task of selecting a winner for
today's slam at the end of the hour
they will judge each five minute story
on the following criteria
one theme how well does it relate to the
theme of resilience
two clarity is the story and any
scientific concepts in the story
easy to understand and originality
is the story uniquely captivating and is
it memorable
the winner will receive a cash
reward this amazing trophy
and a giant mcgovern swag bag filled
with goodies
and of course the prestige of being
named the winner of the first ever
mcgovern institute's toy store
a few quick housekeeping notes this
event is being recorded
if you like what you hear tonight please
tag us and help us spread the word on
social media
and our hashtag is mcgovern stories
without further ado
let's get started now to introduce our
storytellers i
asked them all a question and i asked
them if you could go back in time
to march and stockpile anything
absolutely anything
what would it be when i asked our first
storyteller
our first storyteller ola ozeranov
palcik this question
she answered post-testing fmri data for
her study
and stock in zoom please welcome hola
i was nine when my family made the
journey from the former soviet union to
israel
we arrived with four overflowing
suitcases and one
broken floor lamp immigrants have to
make irrational decisions on which
items to bring under for my family it
was a floor lamp that we carried with us
through two countries on our journey to
the promised land for my husband's
family it was two soviet tennis rackets
when we left russia we left behind our
family our home and our identity
but we had a lot to look forward to my
parents were hopeful to escape the
poverty and anti-semitism of the soviet
union
my sister and i were excited about all
the things that the western world had to
offer
mostly bubblegum we settled in a
and government furnished apartment and i
anxiously waited for the boxes we
shipped from russia to arrive
my books were in these boxes i was an
avid reader as a child and although we
didn't have
much i remember always being very proud
of the wall-to-wall shelves of books my
family had
the books allowed me to escape my narrow
world of
long food lines for the magnificent
worlds experienced by the heroes in my
books
our books are boxes arrived three months
later mostly intact except for two
things that didn't make a journey
a folder full of my art and a box of my
books
as for my art i gradually accepted my
parents explanation that my art was
confiscated by the authorities
because it represented valuable cultural
artifacts forbidden to leave russia
one of these these days i'm sure i'll
find them in the hermitage
i was devastated by the loss of my books
we were among the early wave of the mass
migration of soviet jews to israel
and when we arrived there were no
russian language books to be found
anywhere and so i was left bookless
the irony of the russian immigrants to
israel that in russia we were never
russians we were jews
it said so in our identity cards in
israel however we were never israelis
we were russian the reality that they
will never truly belong in this new
country
became evident to me within the first
few days in my new school when i arrived
to school wearing a traditional russian
first day of school dress with balls in
my hair
just to find everyone else dressed
comfortably in sweatpants
i was desperate to belong in mastering
the language was my entry ticket
at first i had a slow start for my first
few months we were in israel my mom paid
me five cents per page to motivate me to
read children's picture books
i went from reading around the world in
80 days in russian
to laboriously decoding a red pyjama in
hebrew
one word at a time it was painful and
demoralizing and i felt like a bird
without wings
i was ready to pack up my belongings and
travel back to russia in pursuit of my
lost art
but the week before summer vacation my
class took a trip to local library to
pick out our summer readings
and i came across a book about a boy in
a foster family
that was a part of an eight book series
i was immediately sucked in and by the
end of the summer i finished all the
books in the series and by september 1st
i was
so fluent in hebrew that i was exempt
from the language learners program at my
school
reading with my anchor and my outlet
through our many moves over the
following years
through my very rough adolescence books
of existential philosophers gave me a
grand perspective on my teenage angsts
in the small and isolated kibbutz where
i was sent to escape the bad influences
of my neighborhood
in the remote military base where i
served for two years
and in my early days in the u.s when i
began attending community college my
reading
is what helped me survive and even
thrive
reading was everything to me and so i
was struck when i first encountered the
child who couldn't read
given my passion for reading it's not
surprising that during my junior year of
college i began working at the institute
for reading research
i evaluated the efficacy of a curriculum
developed by the institute researchers
and through this work
i would regularly visit schools in
wealthy suburban inner city and
immigrant neighborhoods to administer
reading assessments to children
at regular intervals i was struck at the
variability with which children made
progress from month to month
some kids could read effortlessly others
with a bit more difficulty and then
there were children like ruben
who had developmental dyslexia reuben
was a bright and chatty second grader
who in the span of her walk
down the hall from his classroom to the
testing room but not only update me on
his latest lego creations
but also in the most intimate details of
his family's life like
his aunt rachel's divorce we would enter
the testing room and his face would
visibly fall
reuben would sit in front of me every
two weeks frustrated with
tears welling up in his eyes trying his
hardest
to read through a passage word by word
by word just like i did so many years
ago
but for him this wasn't a fleeting
hiccup but the beginning of a lifelong
struggle
this experience sparked my passion to
unravel the neural mechanisms of
individual differences in reading
development
in the research here at mcgovern
institute we've been discovering the
children at risk for developmental
dyslexia show brain alterations
often associated with this disorder as
early as first few months of
kindergarten
despite substantial hereditary and
behavioral risk however some children
proceed to develop typical reading
skills and the research shows that these
children often recruit alternative
neural pathways and use different
cognitive strategies for reading
so i'm interested in figuring out these
mechanisms of risk and resilience in
reading development
because i believe that reading is not
only a privilege and an anchor as it was
for me
but a basic human right that all
children should enjoy
thank you
yay to ola thank you so much for being
our first storyteller i
love that story and i have such a clear
image of the determined little girl
who loves bubble gum and wants to find a
way to read
thank you for bringing her into the room
with you tonight
our next storyteller is jill crittenden
and when i asked jill what she would
stockpile if she could go back in time
to march she answered
stock in zoom but she added she is not
ready to tell us what she would do with
the prophets
please welcome jill thank you
for the rest is usually considered a
good thing it takes perseverance to
learn skills
like riding a bike every time you fall
off you have to get back on
again and again in fact if you've ever
had dinner with a toddler
you know that even a simple behavior
like feeding yourself takes perseverance
and repetition
after a while the whole sequence of
movements required for whatever task
you're doing seems effortless
and we just go on autopilot but
sometimes that autopilot is our own
worst enemy and
unconsciously initiates harmful habits
like nail biting or smoking
in many brain disorders such as autism
and schizophrenia repetitive behaviors
can be severe and very difficult to
disrupt
people become so stuck doing the same
thing over and over again
that they seem completely unaware of the
world around them
a few years ago i was studying the
biological basis of these extreme
repetitive behaviors in ann graybiel's
lab
and we made a remarkable discovery about
why they might sometimes be so hard to
disrupt
that's interesting in and of itself but
the resilience part of my story
is about what happened when we tried to
publish our discovery
we were doing experiments to test which
neurons in the brain disrupt a habit
for example if someone says stop biting
your nails which neurons hear it
and make you stop we were using
genetically engineered mice to study
this so that we could actually control
the activity of specific brain cells to
figure out which
ones disrupt the autopilot to induce the
repetitive behaviors we used amphetamine
you might or might not know that
amphetamine causes really
extreme repetitive behaviors that are
really hard to disrupt like skin picking
or pacing
our big discovery was that these extreme
repetitive behaviors
were not interruptible like they should
be the autopilot was deaf
and could not be turned off when you
were exposed to amphetamine
our discovery suggested that in other
cases of pathological repetitive
behaviors
when people are very engaged and seem to
not even
hear the people who are trying to
interrupt them in fact
the habit part of their brain might not
even be getting the signal that
somebody's trying to talk to them
when we were writing up this exciting
discovery for publication
kaboom a canadian group unexpectedly
published a paper
about the genetically engineered mice we
had used
and they said that these mice when they
were trying to solve a task
in a maze kept turning the wrong way
over and over again
bug what did that mean about the
discovery we'd made about repetitive
behaviors using these very same mice
our team had an emergency meeting and we
figured out how to edit our manuscript
and incorporate the canadian group's
findings into our paper
and then we sent it to a talk journal
and we waited
let me tell you a bit about the
manuscript review process it has
multiple steps
the first one is to interest the journal
editors enough to send your paper out
for review by other scientists
we succeeded with that step the second
hurdle is peer review
when experts in your field critique your
manuscript line by line
there are often only two reviewers of
your manuscript but a third reviewer
might be added as a tiebreaker
if the first two don't see eye to eye so
reviewer number three
is the term that's often used to the
most harsh critic of your work
finally our reviews were back and we had
three of them
i carefully read through the requested
changes to our manuscript line by line
but when i got to reviewer number three
my heart sank
number three said that what the canadian
group had said about the genetically
engineered mice that we'd used was a
deal breaker
and that we had to repeat all of our
experiments with a completely different
method this would take many many months
moreover a key member of our team was
just about to move
away to california i felt like reviewer
number three had broken both my kneecaps
but i found out i could still stand back
up
and go in the lab well we set up the new
experimental methods and looked for a
replacement team member
we looked more closely at the behavioral
mice we decided to use
and we found that there repetitive
behaviors in fact went on much longer
than in normal mice
and we found that the genetic mutation
in them
actually might be related to this in the
habit part of the brain how gene
expression had changed
so this was interesting because it shows
how a genetic mutation can make
someone more vulnerable to have these
extreme repetitive behaviors
we wrote up the story and we published
it without much trouble
eventually we were able to get the
requested new experiments done as well
and we published our discovery about how
amphetamine can make the
habit driving autopilot numb to inputs
so in the end we got two papers
out of the rejection by reviewer number
three
so when you read that review be
resilient
persevere maybe you can make lemonade
out of lemons
and a huge congratulations to our second
storyteller
thank you so much this is a story i love
because it bets us
in on the inside baseball of science and
the scientific process
i know that there would be many in our
audience who understand just how
terrifying reviewer number three
can be so thank you so much jill
our next storyteller is christy johnson
and when i asked what she would have
stockpiled if she could go back in time
to march she gave an answer very very
dear to my heart she said she would have
stockpiled
infinite child care please welcome
christy
you know that moment in movies where the
character
stares off into space and the camera
zooms in through their eyeball and
magically
flashes up all the memories all the
moments in their life that led up to
that one
particular moment that was me on march
8th 2012.
i was in indiana sitting on the beige
carpet of my parents living room
my best friend's father had just passed
away suddenly and i'd flown home with my
nine-month-old son to be with her
while i was on the plane and my son's
neurologist had called
he left a message saying you need to
come in
which you know is never a great thing to
hear from a neurologist
the month before we'd been referred to
him because my son felix
had missed every single milestone
he wasn't rolling over he couldn't sit
didn't babble didn't use his hands for
anything not to
grab a toy or touch my face by the time
we saw the neurologist
he immediately called for genetic
testing
so while i was at the funeral for my
best friend's father my husband was back
in california where we were living at
the time
listening to the doctor tell him that
felix was missing a handful of genes
one gene in particular was critical for
development
and he didn't have it there were seven
known
cases worldwide at that time but
specific patterns had already begun to
emerge
all these children had absent speech
meaning no
spoken words ever they had severe
intellectual disabilities epilepsy
autistic traits motor challenges
at that time there were no cases of
individuals who could walk they
struggled to use their hands and plan
movements
and it would be lifelong and that night
as my husband relayed this information
to me over the phone
as i was already exhausted and raw
and overwhelmed by the capriciousness
of life and death i felt an
extraordinary sensation
of clarity that was the moment
when all the pieces of my life fast
forwarded to me
sitting on the beige carpeted corner of
the living room
up until that moment i had thought i was
going to be an astrophysicist
uh before getting married and having
felix i'd been on a relatively straight
academic path in physics
i've been a goldwater scholar i
graduated sumo [ __ ] laude with honors
minors math and astronomy all the usual
stuff i'd gone straight into a phd
program out of undergrad but none of
that
mattered anymore so instead of returning
to finish my phd
i stayed home in the evenings i taught
college astronomy and edited
scientific manuscripts and grants to pay
the bills but when felix was awake
i was with him and in every spare second
i was reading about autism genetics
neuroscience anything i could get my
hands on that might help
i began tinkering with arduinos
fabricating toys and tools
it was clear that if i wanted a better
world for felix
more knowledge better tools deeper
understanding
i was going to have to build it myself
eventually my husband finished his phd
we moved to boston for his postdoc and
felix started at a special school
for the first time since that night in
indiana i
considered going back to finish my phd
except physics wasn't the love of my
life anymore
felix was not
everyone found that as poetic as i did
and i was routinely rejected from
every position that i applied to then
while reading an
oprah magazine my mother had left in our
bathroom i learned about the media lab
and i knew i had found it the academic
island of
misfit toys finally i would fit
in graduate school has been this
winding wild ride across disciplines
trying to figure out the fundamentals
necessary
to build a whole field of study around
individuals with severe intellectual
disabilities nonverbal or minimally
verbal communication
and multiple diagnoses including autism
i built devices sensors algorithms ran
studies
eventually i found my way to
neuroscience and began working with
members of the gabrielli lab
on a project to study the neural basis
of affinities
those deep passionate interests that
individuals with autism and indeed
all of us often have felix's world
revolves around music it's the way we
connect with him it's the way he
regulates and so
socializes the greatest way to make him
laugh is a glissando
like like wiley coyote falling off a
cliff
splat so instead of asking how to
minimize this love or how it interferes
with his life
we lean in we ask how these affinities
can enhance
or strengthen skills my research is
based on what people
can do how they thrive not the
ways in which they're deficient or
lacking another project studies
non-verbal and minimally verbal
individuals
from vocalizations like
these are non-speech but deeply
informative modes of communication
we've built an end-to-end pipeline to
capture these vocalizations in the wild
machine learning algorithms to classify
them and we're developing a tool that
shares the meaning behind these sounds
in real time
to enhance the communication between
non-verbal individuals
and the world we're trying to change the
question from
why don't they speak to how do
they communicate here's the thing
there is a lot that felix can't do
but there's also so much that he can
in life we often don't get to choose the
path we're on
but we do get to choose what we're going
to do on the journey
thank you so much christy for that
beautiful story and thank you
so much for introducing us all to felix
and for being the sort of person who
faces a problem
head-on and with so much love please
welcome our next storyteller
merti ramadan when i asked him what he
would stockpile if he could go back in
time too much
he said something that i think we all
would love a little bit more of these
days
clorox wipes please welcome merci
thank you my story begins with my mom's
sister and i being evacuated by u.s
marines from war-torn lebanon to cyprus
i remember finding a cotton candy
machine on the battleship we were on
and just for a fleeting moment i could
enjoy being a kid not a kid terrified
of what he's just experienced not a kid
terrified of what lies ahead
after five long days we finally arrived
in the seattle airport
and a strong smell of coffee welcomed us
to our new home
and our new way of life now this might
seem like a triumphant moment
that now we're saved but it's not always
that simple
as we made our way home i remember a mix
of emotion
we were joyful and relieved but at the
same time nervous
are we going to be okay here
with sudden change come sudden maturity
and even at a
young age of 11 years old i realized i
had opportunities here in the united
states i didn't have
back in lebanon i was absolutely
fascinated by
the brain and mathematics and i dreamt
that one day
i want to go to college and i want to
become a neuroscientist just like my
hero oliver sacks
as we settled into life in seattle
everything seemed
bright but then one day our foundation
came crashing down my dad had his second
heart attack
but this time it was different this time
he lost his job medical bills piled up
we actually had to relocate from our
home to government housing
to afford rent i felt as if the ground
beneath us
began to crumble and i started asking
myself
am i going to be okay will i still be
able to attend college one day
i'm still going to become a
neuroscientist right
as the years passed by my dream of
attending college became more like a
figment of
my imagination started noticing
a growing gap between myself and my
friends
while they during their summers went to
summer camps for robotics coding science
and sports
i stayed home while they received new
computers and video
game consoles for their birthdays i did
not
while they started touring college
campuses with their families and getting
private tutors to help them with the
sats and personal statements my family
could barely afford a car to get around
with
at this time i was nearing the end of my
high school years
so i had to face my reality and make a
decision
is college still a possibility for me or
should i
pursue something more practical and get
a job and support my family financially
um and i had discussions with my family
about college and it was
full of uncertainty questions like even
if i get into college who's going to pay
for it
what are these scholarships and are they
a scam
why in neuroscience maybe i could pick
something easier
what if this whole college thing this
whole
university this whole academia science
thing it's just not made for families
like us a pivotal moment came
when one of our family friends laura who
had known me since i was
two years old and knew how bad i wanted
to go to college
basically forced me to apply uh for a
high school summer research internship
at the university of washington i was so
sure
that i wouldn't get into the internship
why pick me out of all the kids
but to my surprise i got chosen
the the the feeling that somebody out
there actually saw potential in me
even though at that time i didn't see
potential in myself
is what inspired me to actually go to
the internship
now on the the end of the first day of
my internship
i thought i had made a huge huge huge
mistake
the kids around me they were so smart so
confident
they already knew how to code it's it's
as if they've trained for this
moment their whole life i i just didn't
belong there
i should go back on the second day of
the internship
i learned i was placed in a lab that
dealt with
a left ventricular assist device which
is a system that you implant for heart
failure patients
and in that moment i really thought
about my dad and his heart problems
and that intrigued me what is this
device and how could i ever contribute
to this device into these people
and that's what pushed me to go in the
third day
on the third day i was given my first
task which is to code up
a small piece of code to simulate the
heat properties of one of
the components that have to go inside
the patient and
we have to make sure that it doesn't
burn the tissue of the patient
i'm terrified i've never coded before
i've never even opened a program before
why did they pick me why not just
another student who should do it
but at that moment i had to stop and
think
what if i don't take this opportunity
what would my life look like
what if i'm forever constrained by the
the financial circumstances that were
handed down to me
but in that moment i decided to take
control
and it took me two weeks to create this
little piece of code
but in those two weeks i created that
piece of code and little did i know
that this little piece of code would
create the
coil design for the component that
selected out of many in the lab
would end up being used for the first
clinical trials the system underwent
and not only that but it turned out
later on that my coil design was as
close to optimal
as it could be this is the first time
that i felt the ground
solidify and that the first step i took
in this path
wasn't muddy that it didn't sink me and
i didn't make a fool of
myself that actually this is a path that
i can take
and that i want to take i could go back
to my family and say
that i have a contribution and impact to
make in the world and that i can do it
and that college might just be the thing
for me
inspired i uh got into
applied and gotten to the university of
washington
took part of ever more computational uh
pieces of work in research anything from
seizure predictions to models of visual
cortex
and i'm proud to say that here at mit
i've actually
had the privilege of teaching
programming and how to code to incoming
graduate students in the department
and now as part of the jazieri lab i
studied the computational basis of
counter-factual thinking
the same sort of cognitive processes
that went on in that pivotal
moment when i thought what if i take
this opportunity
but what if i don't and today i share my
story
for those of you out there who feel like
me and i want to tell you
that you don't have to be constrained by
the financial circumstances you were
born in
that you can follow the passions of your
heart and the most important thing you
have is not money or connections
but the belief people have in you and
the belief that you have in yourself
and i'm here to say to you that i
believe in you
thank you
thank you so much maddie for such a
wonderful
journey that from being on a boat with
the marines
to the jazz lab at mit there's an
incredible story thank you so much
our final storyteller for tonight is
heather kozikowski
and when i asked her what she would
stockpile that she could go back in time
to march
she said and i feel like we're all with
her too hugs
because she's so misses seeing people
please welcome
heather
have you ever experienced hate
not the haters gonna hate kind of hate
but someone's deep
loathing directed toward you when
someone hits you
that much their face becomes so
distorted with rage
they are unrecognizable violence is
inevitable
and if you happen to be brave enough or
stupid enough
to look into that person's eyes well
there are no words to describe the
intensity of hate-filled eyes
in that moment the object of hatred
becomes just that
an object and ceases to exist
at least that's how it felt for me my
mom had the ability to knead me
with one breath and in the next be
filled with such rage and utter hate
that bruises were inevitable
and my life was in peril how do you
survive
the hatred of your own mother
resilience great perseverance
those words have marked my entire life
and they are not words i am proud of
behind those words are a lot of pain
a lot of overcoming a lot of surviving
sexual physical and mental abuse
homeless shelters welfare foster care
the marine corps systems and structures
that broke me
failure after failure after failure
and somehow for some unknown reason
i have still fought still persevered
still survived
my whole life i only ever dreamed of two
things going to college and having a
family
at the age of 26 i started taking
classes at the local community college
a few short months later i was pregnant
i dropped out a baby
messed up little me was going to have a
baby
how could someone like me that has never
been loved
ever give love when she was born
my sweet little baby girl i was filled
with such awe
and wonder in the maternity ward i would
carefully swaddle her place her in her
bassinet and just stare
her cute little cheeks her sweet little
nose her perfect little eyes
wrapped in her knitted purple blanket
and matching hat that nurses came went
came and went every few hours one
particularly puffy a nurse bounded and
oh my gosh she is so sweet i bet you are
just hugging her and kissing her
all the time then she took her vitals
and left
kissing her i can do that
she was two days old and it had never
once occurred to me to kiss
my own daughter right then and there i
tried it
it felt awkward at first this learning
to love thing
but also right i started to learn all
the mom things baby baths and bouncing
and burping and diapers and swaddles
one day when she was just about six
weeks old she cried
and cried and cried and there was
nothing
literally nothing i could do as she
cried i made all sorts of promises to
her
i told her it was okay mommy was there
she was safe i told her that i love her
and in that moment i knew it was true
a few months later the afternoon
sunlight was streaming through the
window
with smashed avocado and sweet potato
stains all over the counter i looked
down into this sweet baby girl's eyes
into my daughter's eyes and i realized
i want the world for her i want her to
know that she can do anything she wants
looking at her i realize that if i want
her to truly believe she can accomplish
her dreams
i would have to accomplish mine and so i
set out on a journey of self-discovery
of academic inquiry i came back to the
question that has haunted me since
childhood
what drives people to hate
a few years later i found the paper that
transformed my thinking
i had already learned that hate happens
when we failed to see the humanity in
others
but this paper explained the neural
mechanisms that enable us to actually
see someone else's pain then it occurred
to me
if i want to understand what happens
when thing goes things go wrong
when people learn to hate i have to
start at the beginning
before we learn to hate i have to start
with babies
have you ever looked into the eyes of a
baby oh my gosh
if you have it you need to try it there
is nothing more heavenly in this world
babies give and receive love at any
moment
with any human not yet closed off to the
realities of this harsh world human
babies have a way of
innocently connected with anyone that's
willing and saying
i am here with you and i see you
as you are here with me it
is powerful so i set out to better
understand babies
the place where we all begin before we
learn to hate but are capable of immense
love
how do babies see the world my person to
understand how infant brains support
their minds
is a new dream when i wouldn't have even
their dream that fateful day in my
kitchen so many years ago
it has been hard so hard
i have cried a lot i have lost
a lot but i have also shown my daughter
that not only can she achieve achieve
her dreams
she can have dreams beyond her wildest
imagination
you all i am a phd student at mit do you
know how unheard of it is for a foster
kid to get a bachelor's degree let alone
a phd
and yet here i am a foster kid phd
candidate at mit
doing the kind of research that only a
handful of people in the world
have even attempted over the last few
years i have held
comforted swaddled and looked into the
eyes
and brains of over a hundred babies
with every ounce of my being i want to
know what is happening
in their mind right now and with each
baby that i meet
i stare into their eyes just as deeply
as they look into mine and make sure
they know
just like my daughter did that i am
there
with them seeing them as they
see me
heather thank you so much for such a
beautiful story
it reminds me to spend a little bit more
time
looking into my baby's eyes and thank
you so much for being so generous
in sharing it with us tonight now before
our judges get started
on figuring out a winner i want to give
you a
quick recap of everything that we've
heard tonight
in moving from russia to israel ola lost
her ability to read
a moment that shaped her work as a
researcher
jill overcame rejection from that
dreaded reviewer number three
christy told us of a complete career
change to develop technology to help her
son
melty overcame incredible odds and
self-doubt to pursue
a dream of coding after a promise to her
father
shannon secured his career led her to
the boyden lab and who what knows where
next deepon's late night eureka moment
in the lab cemented his ability as an
independent researcher
and finally heather told us how she
found a new lease on life
after the birth of her daughter
and now our judges maddie and tina will
be
selecting today's winning story they've
already ducked into a magical
behind the scenes green room for the
next two minutes
and while they're gone you'll be able to
see some photos
submitted by our storytellers that
illustrate each of our storytellers
lives and stories and now while we can't
see you tonight
we have a chat function open and all of
our storytellers can see it
so while our judges are deliberating
please let us know if you're having a
good time
and which stories you loved and we'll
see you back here in two minutes
three years ago
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
down
[Music]
your dreams
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
welcome back to our judges maddie and
tina
um that took slightly longer because
they had a really unenviable task of
having to decide
who would be the winner so thank you so
much and i will hand it over to both of
them for their decision
okay so that was ridiculously difficult
um i want to say first of all thank you
to all of our storytellers it is
not easy to tell a story it is not easy
to tell a personal story and it is not
easy to tell a story over zoom i will
say that
for sure so you know we were judging on
a lot of different
themes we were dodging on themes
originality um
and it was a really tough decision
because i feel like
so many of our storytellers today nailed
it
um but there was one storyteller in
in particular that also did
a great job delivering the story there
was story structure um
and and then and i'll talk a little bit
more after this because i don't want to
keep it from you guys but are we we
chose christie johnson
as our winner tonight and um
you know as a person who professionally
tells science stories i have to say that
christie did
so many beautiful things in which
there was an emotional start there was a
touch point for us
we all see the movies where like life
flashes before the eyes right
um and then we chrissy did a great job
of doing something we call signposting
which is kind of leaving us
little things along the way that we're
gonna find
big climactic moment beautiful
resolution
and the story was really rounded out and
so
uh you know i'm going to turn it over to
tina to say a little bit more but
there were some beautiful stories
of resilience tonight and i just want to
say thank you again
it was it was a very difficult choice
but christy congratulations
yeah i would like to echo what maddie
said
every single one of you told a great
story
you all had terms of phrase that i
envy so much and would love to have
stolen
um and christy uh what really
sort of touched me most was
how you said that you're not looking for
the ways
these children are defective but the
ways in which they
thrive and i think that that is so
important
and that is the definition of resilience
so congratulations
thanks
i also want to say for everybody one
thing that i always tell scientists that
come on our show
is that your passion your
vulnerability if you choose to have that
comes through more than any amounts of
practice or
lack of jargon or whatever and i will
say that it's hard to do that over zoom
but christy i feel
as though um you know your emotion your
enthusiasm your
vulnerability to really pulls people in
and people want to pay attention
um when you can tell somebody is really
passionate about something and so many
people did that today but christie i
thought you did a great job of that too
so there's all kinds of practicing and
lack of jargon and that you can do but
really being
truly driven by something important to
you is there's no replacement for that
so congratulations christy and
to everybody else too
so congratulations to christy the winner
of the first ever
mcgovern story slam this very glamorous
trophy
is on its way to you as well as a giant
mcgovern
swag bag i want to thank our judges
maddy's fire and tina hesman say for
their time tonight
and i really want to thank all of you
for taking the time to join us online
and finally and most importantly i want
to thank all of our storytellers
ola jill christie merti shannon deepon
and heather
for opening up and sharing so much of
themselves with us tonight
if you enjoyed this slam please visit
the mcgovern institute website
to learn more about future events and
other ways to stay involved
thank you and have a great evening
[Music]
[Music]